今日は七十二ページのヘートサンガーだろうと思います
このヘートというのは原因ということなんですけど
まあでもアビダンマではその原因という意味で使ってないんです
で ヘート まあ一般仏教用語だったら
ヘートっていうのはこの因果法則で言ってる因の話なんですね
で アビダンマではまあほんのちょっと違う意味で使っているし
それははっきりと意味は違いますよということは言ってるんですね
だからといってそれは因果法則だと思ったら
それは間違いであります
えーと 因果法則の場合は
もう別に因の話で言っても
すべてのものは因になりますから
因にならないものは何一つもないし
すべてのものはまたある面で果であって
何か今存在している現象っていうのは
ある原因の結果だから
だから我々のすべての現象は果でありますし
その現象は次の現象の因になってしまいますから
一つのものは因であって果でありますよ
ですから まあそれは因果法則の話になりますけどね
それで我々は聞きたがるのはそうじゃなくて
どんな因縁でどんな結果が得るかという
きちんと二つに分けてしっかりした説明なんですね
あなたは親を親を叱ったんだから今日は怪我しましたよとかね
今あんた病気になっているのは
もうご先祖様にちゃんとお線香をあげなかったからですよとかね
ああいうふうなことを聞きたがりますけどね
それは他のところで聞いていただきたいんだけど
で こちらの因というのは
アビダンマだけで考えている因で
意味はこの善悪決める因なんですね
善と悪を決める因 で 心の働きの場合は
この心の働きが善ですか悪ですか
どちらに分けますか いわゆる黒いか白いかと分ける場合は
これで分けてみます それはどういうことかというと
貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴なんですね
漏婆 ドーサ モーハ アローバ
アドーサ アモーハという六つ
その心所なんですね でも五十二の心所のセットの中で
まあそんなに明確に漏婆ドーサモーハ
漏婆ドーサは出たんだけど
まあモーハも出ました出たんだけど
逆にアローバっていうのはどこにあるか出てこなかったし
アドーサはまあどこにあるか出てこなかったし
しっかりは で アモーハはまあパンニャーとして特別には出てきましたけど
まあそこら辺ははっきりしてないんだけど
で アローバっていうのはまあどこに出てきたんでしょうかね
えーと  共同心相  どんな前でしたっけ
慈悲心  そちらアローバドーサ入ってますね
アローバドーサ入ってあって
パンニャーは別に入ってるんですね
大体ヘートサンガーっていうのはそれだけのことで終わります
で 心所の中に もし貪瞋痴が二つか三つが入っているならば
黒い 不善なんですね で
入る まあ起こる場合は
無痴とむさぼり 無痴と怒り
どっちかのセットで埋まるんですね
ですから 不善たる行為の基本は無痴なんですね
いわゆるこちらで言ってる痴ですね
アモーハ モーハ モーハで決めるんですね
心にモーハがあったら
まあそれはもう不善であると
その上に漏婆が入ったり
ドーサが入ったりする
で 私たちが知っているのは漏婆は知ってますけど
ドーサは知ってますけど
なかなかモーハはなかなか知らないんですね
でもほとんど二十四時間でやってる行動というのは
ほとんどただやっているだけで
何も智慧やら理解やら
まあそういうのは働いてないんだからね
だからほとんどモーハが活動してるんですよ
必ずも で その中でたまに欲が出たら
あ 私は今欲が出て心が汚れているんだと
もう思ったりするんだけど
この前も汚れているんですよ
で 怒りが出たら ああ やっぱり心が汚れましたとかね
嫉妬が生まれたら やっぱり汚れたんだから何とかしなくちゃとかね
本当はその前からもずっと汚れてるんです
ただ 嫉妬やら怒りやら生まれたらもうすぐ気づくだけ
自分が何か嫉妬しているんではないかと
随分悩んでると 自分が悩んでるんではないかと気づくだけのことで
もともと無知だから いわゆる無明だから悩んでるんですからね
ですから まあそういう風に簡単にこの知の働き
無明の働きは見えないかもしれません
で まあ私は今すごく明るくて活発的で
すごい理解があって 自分が何のためにどういうことをやってるんですかと
そういうふうな行動をする時は
もしかすると無明が働いてないかもしれません
無明が働いてない場合は
もうきちんとしたこの善心になりますね
で 善心で 人のために 自分のために
きちんとした行動をやる
何か考えるということはほとんど少ないでしょうに
1日中ただ単に生きてるだけのことですから
無明の方が多いと思いますよ
ですから そのただ生きてるだけのことの中で欲が生まれたり
怒りが生まれたりする
その時だけ気づくと あ
やっぱり汚れたんだと
で 普段の心もやっぱり汚れてるというのは汚れてるんですね
とにかくこの心が黒く
黒いか白いかと分けたい場合は
貪瞋痴か不貪不瞋痴愚痴
その六つで決めるんですね
善心性の場合は 智慧がいつでもあるかどうかわかりませんだけど
やっぱり むさぼりが消えちゃうと
その逆のエネルギー 愛想のエネルギーが生まれると
いわゆる献身的な気持ちになる瞬間で
もう他の心相もついてくるんですね
自分のためではなくて
いわゆる他の何とかね
してあげたいような気持ちが生まれた瞬間で
心も体もかなり明るくて元気なんですよ
大体人が結構元気じゃないと
人のために何かしてあげるってことできないんですよ
自分のことで手一杯だから
自分のために行動することで
ですから どうせ善心性が生まれると人は元気で明るいということになっちゃうんです
ですから 余裕ある心なんですね
だから心に余裕があって
人のために またかえって自分のためにも有効に行動する時は善心ですね
その上で智慧も入っちゃうと
仏教で智慧というのはもう知識ではなくて
物事を無常であることを体験することなんですね
無常であるということを体験しちゃうと
なんかそういうものから離れたくなる
捕まりたくなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 物事を変化していくんだ
消えていくんだと そんなもんだと消えていくんだというふうな気持ちになると
大変大事な高価な何かしら物があって
それは壊れたんだとかね
ヒビが入ったんだ その時でも
やっぱりそんな作ったものだから
いつか壊れるだろうと
[笑い]当たり前だよ
そんなことはとかね 思う瞬間で
それに対して何も取れ柄がないんですね
大事な食器が割れちゃったんだと
でもやっぱりそんなものも割れるもんだと
で 思っている瞬間で心が落ち着いてるんですね
その時は智慧が働いているんです
だから強引にでも無常のことを頭に入れておくたびに智慧が働き始まるんですよ
物は変化するんだと もう全ては瞬間瞬間変化して消えていくんだと
止まっている停止しているものやら
実体的なものは何もないんだ
あるいは自分の希望通りには一つも行くはずがないんだと
物は物の法則の通りに動いているんだと
自分でわがままでいろんなことをああなってほしい
こうなってほしいと思ったっても
そうはならないんだと
ということは この頭だけでわかっているんだけど
心では認めたくないでしょうね
心では何でも自分の希望通りに行ってほしいし
必死になってそういうふうに努力はするし
希望通りならなかったらものすごくそれでもう感情的になってトラブルを作っちゃうし
それで苦しみが生まれてくるし
そういう法則でいっちゃえば
お釈迦様が言うのは一つも希望通りにいかないんだと
何一つも希望通りにいかないんです
全ては法則 因果法則によって動いているんであって
私たちにはどうすることもできない
私たちも因果法則の一部だけであって
因果法則から離れたわけでもないし
ただ今自由意識を持って考えたりするのは
それも因果法則によってできているもので
自由かどうかちょっとわからないんですね
ですから もう何一つも希望通りにはいかない
それは因果法則の説明である
それで人間というのは何でも希望通りにいきたがって
いってほしがっちゃいますから
我々の生き方はどういう生き方かというと
生まれた時から死ぬ瞬間までもういつでも努力しているのは
自分が希望をそこで その希望はとにかく叶ってもらおうということなんですね
ですから 生きることはそのまま苦しみになるんですね
だからありえないことにチャレンジしているんだからね
得られない結果を得ようとしているんだから
そこに失望感 虚しさというものは感じるのはもう避けられないことなんですね
そこに無知が働いて でも希望通りにいってるんではないかと
と無知が働いてヘリクツと言っちゃうんですね
いくらかでも一部でも希望通りにいってるんではないかと
で 本当のところは一部でも希望通りにはいってないんで
例えば一生懸命努力して仕事をしたら
まあ金儲かるんではないかと
本当にそうであるならば
今商売やってみてください
何でもいいんだから 株を買ったり
ああだこうだとかね そうは希望通りにいかないんですよ
で 今どこか誰かが何か会社なんか作っちゃって
商売人にたっても で 投資したお金終わっちゃったらそれで終わりと
だからまあ世の中うまく動いていると
お金が回っていると 自分がなんとかくだらない会社作ったっても
それでも金いくらか回ってくるかもしれませんし
ただ 雨が降っていると
外へ出たら雨に濡れただけのことなんです
ですから そんな一つも希望通りにいくわけがないんです
例えば薬の場合でも 食べ物の場合でも
こういうこういう食べ物を食べたら
こういうこういうふうに体が結果がありますよと言っても
本当にそうなるんですかというと
そうは百パーセント確実性はないんですよ
それなのに我々はそう思っちゃうんです
玄米ご飯を食べたら健康になるんだとか
それだったら玄米ご飯を食べてみてください
その人々よりも確実に病気になったりはするし
そういうことは全くないんです
だから自然の食べ物を食べると体にいいんだというだけのことで
それは我々の希望であって
もしその通りになるならば
純粋に自然食をね もうなんとかビオティックなんとかって言いますからね
そういう食べ物を作って食べている人々は完全に元気で健康的にいるはずであるし
病気にならないと健康的でいるならば死なないはずであろうし
そうはならないし ですから
一つも希望通りにはいかないというのはもう正しい考え方なんですけどね
人間が何でも希望通りにしてやりますと
と努力する でも結局は失敗で終わります
ということで 生は生きることは苦になってしまうんですね
だから生きていることは苦しみであると
ドゥッカであるということは
こんな人間に決して変化する
変化することできる真理ではない言葉じゃない
あれは真理だから それはもう絶対的なその通りであります
問題は我々にあるんで
それは認めたくないだけのことです
ですからまあ我々にはこの知恵というのは
パンニャーっていうのはいつでもあるんじゃないんですね
で 強引にでも そういう認めたくないものでも
強引にでも考えたり その通りに判断しようとすると知恵が働き始まるんです
仕事はするんだけど やっぱり全部希望通りに行くわけじゃないと
それは覚悟しておけば
そこに知恵が働いてるんです
だから 本当に知恵がある人は働くんであって
希望は消えちゃう 消しちゃうんです
希望はなしと そう言っちゃうと
みんななんか暗いでしょうと
やっぱり人は希望があって頑張るんだと
だから人は希望があって苦しいんだと
あのリスなんか買っちゃうと
買って檻に入れちゃうと
なんか丸く回る何か道具入れちゃうんですよ
そこにリスが入っちゃって歩くこと
あるいは回る回るすごい速いスピードで回っちゃうんですね
リスはどこにも行ったことはないんです
いくら走っても同じ場所にいるんですね
自分入った檻が回ってるんだから
そこでリスがよく今日歩きましたとか
よく旅に出ますと勘違いしたっても
どこにも行ってないんです
疲れちゃうしね あれで結構
ですから 人間っていうのは希望を作って
ただリスみたいに同じところにぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるだけで動いてるだけで
結局疲れて終わりますよ
何かやったことにならないんですね
ですから まあ聖者の道っていうのは何か希望あるかというと
一切希望なしと 一切希望はないんだから
何の苦しみもないし 例えば聖者が托鉢に出たんだと
托鉢に出たんだけど 何の食べ物もお布施をしてもらわなかったと
そうするとほとんど一食ですから
1日 そのお腹が空くでしょうに
だから あんた今日はかわいそうでしょうと
不幸でしょうと 今日は托鉢もらわなかったんだから
そういう感じは全くないんです
托鉢に出る時は出たんだけど
そこに希望はない 今日はもうご飯もらって
それからそれ食べて こういうこういうご飯
美味しいご飯もらうために出るっていうことはないんです
そこで聖者にならなかったお坊さんも
例えば悟ったお坊さんも悟ってないお坊さんが二人托鉢に出ると
外から見れば二人とも同じことをやってるんですよ
托鉢に出て食事をいただいて食べるっていうことで
でも悟ってない人には目的があるんですね
今日 1日の食べ物をいただくために行くんだと
悟ったお坊さんに聞けば目的がないんですね
今托鉢に出るんだと それだけ
で 托鉢の時間終わりました
それで帰るんだと そうすると悟ったお坊さんの場合は
物資にもらったかもらわなかっただからやっぱり今日の旅は失敗です
そういう概念何もない
ただその瞬間 その瞬間行動しただけで
悟ってなかったお坊さんは今日はもう歩いて疲れただけで何ももらわなかったと
今日は本当に一日中疲れるだろうと
修行はできないだろうと
お腹が空いて結構気を苦労しなくちゃとか
いろいろ苦しみがそこに出てくる
たったわずかな希望があったんだから
で そういうのはその心のね
本当にレベル高い働きをね
説明するために仏教の中で物語とかありますけど
それはもうその通りに解釈してないんですね
ある日 お釈迦様はどこかに町に托鉢に出たんですね
托鉢に出て歩いたんだけど
何一つもらわなかったんです
全くこの鉢を洗ったまんまで帰りましたと
で 文学的に書いてるんですね
朝はもう鉢を洗って拭いて
アナンタ尊者がちゃんと洗って拭いてくれるんだから
それを持って街に村に出て
村を歩いて そのまんま洗ったまんまの鉢で帰りましたと
そこに悪魔が出てきて
で もう一回出ると食事をもらうんだと
だからもう一回回ってくださいと
言ったら え 二度とまわりませんよと言ってお釈迦様は帰るんですね
で そこでストーリーで悪魔がマーラがね
悪魔と言っても神ですからね
あいつはこの人々の頭にこの人々を抑えておいて
お布施をしないようにしておいたんだと
それでお釈迦様が帰ってから
このマーラがこのまたこの自分の力ですか
その力を抜いてあげたら
みんなこの作っているご飯をあげるようにという
そういうマーラの仕業
なんとかした仕業というかね
というふうに書いてますけど
そこで二度と 二度もう行きましたから
もう行かないんですよと言われたところで
その何て言いますか 企んだ計画はもううまくいかなかったんですね
で そこは実際にマーラが行ったかどうかはわかりませんだけど
慣れてないところに行ったところで托鉢をもらうということはないし
ですから人は慣れてなかったかもしれませんし
二回行ったならば もしかすると用意してくれる可能性もあったかもしれませんし
でも目的あったならば
食べ物もらうために行くんだと
ならば二回 三回でも回って自分の目的を達成しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
今日は食べ物もらって食べるのは当たり前だというふうな目的を作ったならば
この村でご飯もらわなかったんだから
隣の村に行きましょうと
まだ時間がありますからと
というふうになるんですね
だからそこでこの深い
深いこの聖者の心の働きは
そのわずかなストーリーの中でもちゃんと書いてるんです
なぜ二度と行かなかったかと
そこで行動するんだけど
聖者には目的はない 目的がないんだから
そこには何の苦しみもないと
ですから 真似事でもしてみれば仕事はするんだけど
目的を作らないと たった一日だけでも自分やってることを普通の生活でいいんですよ
普通に毎朝やることを七時にやることを八時にやること
十一時にやることを普通にやればいいんです
でもそれに こういうためにこれをやるんだという目的だけ捨ててやってみてください
かなり違うと そこに何の苦しみも生まれないんだと
全然疲れないんだと わかりますよ
例えば料理を作ると目的すぐ出るでしょうね
すぐ出ちゃうんですね
その目的は達成しないと腹が立っちゃうんです
そうじゃなくて ただ料理を作ると
そこに目的は何もないと
ごく普通に普段作ってるような感じで作ってみたところで
そこで楽しみしか残らないんですね
何かしましたということで終わりますからね
目的達成しましたという公務員が生まれてこないんです
そこで目的達成しましたという公務員が生まれる人にとっては
いつでも失敗しましたという苦しみもそこにいつでもあるんです
とにかく目的はもう決して達成するものではないし
希望はその通りに行くわけじゃないし
物事は法則によって動いているんであって
努力はどうすることもできないんです
人の場合は年取るは 病気になるは
死んでしまうは 病気も年取っていっちゃうとそれなりに体が弱くなっちゃうし
美しさあったってもそれは消えていくし
で それはもう誰にもどうすることもできないし
そこで人間がいろんな目的を作る
健康でいなくちゃいけない
美しくていなくちゃいけない
痩せ 痩せなくちゃいけないとかね
ああだこうだとか目的作る度に生きることは大変な苦しみになるんですね
何で痩せなくちゃいけない目的を作ったんですかというと
自分が何かどこかで間違っているでしょうに
食べる時はね 我々は随分贅沢だから
豊かだからとか言ってそこで食っちゃって
ああだこうだとか もうそれを食べることを楽しむのではない
そこでそういう目的で食べてたんだから
まあそれで目的があって
それで結果が出てきて
それからまた人に比べてみて
やっぱりまた痩せなくちゃいけないと
そこで矛盾だらけで ただもう食べるという行動が起こさなくちゃいけない時間になったら
ただその行動だけする人にとっては食べ過ぎになるとか
ああだこうだとかはありえない話なんですね
ですから 人間が目的作るんだから
そこで矛盾な矛盾というものが生まれてきて
今何かの目的達成したところで
次にその目的から生まれてくる問題を解決するために新しい目的を作らなくちゃいけない
その目的を達成したら
それから生まれる次の問題を解決すると
新しい目的を作らなくちゃいけない
そうやってずっと苦しみが生まれてくる
ですから この知恵のことを喋ってましたけど
そういうようなことを理解して
強引にでも嘘でもいいんだから
この全ては無常であって
希望通りにいかないんだということを強引にでも自分に言い返したりして生きている時は知恵が働いています
知恵が働いた瞬間では
老婆がない 貪りもない
怒りもない だから不貪不瞋不痴という 3つも働いています
アローバ・アドーサモム
その時は心が完璧に清らかで
すごい柔軟性があって
もう喜び幸福を味わっているはずなんです
この喜び幸福っていうのは
何か美味しいものを食べちゃって舞い上がっているような感情じゃないんです
なんか有名な人に握手できたんだからといって
それで体が震えるほど感動した
ああいうのは病気であって
あれでもああいうのは喜びじゃないんですよ
人間喜びだと思っていることは喜びじゃないんですよ
そんな喜びでも何でもないんです
それから病気になるだけですからね
そういう人に会ったら感動するなと思ったら
徹夜して並んでいなくちゃいけないとかね
それは気にしないんですね
ですから 無知な人にはそういう無知な喜び
感情は感じはいますけど
知恵ある人にとってはそういうことはできない
この喜びっていうのは
なんか随分リラックスして落ち着いて
もう何のことなく平和な心でいられるということなんですね
人は悩んでるんだけど
自分は別に悩まないと
人はバカみたいに笑ってるんだけど
自分にとって別に笑う原因もないと
人は嫉妬したりしているんだけど
自分にとって別に別に嫉妬する原因はそこにないんだと
ただ見ているだけで そのまま絶対に
的な平安な心の状態なんです
ある出来事が起きたら
ある人は混乱する ある人は怒る
ある人は嫉妬する ある人は感情
感情が舞い上がっちゃって
もう感情にも陥るとかいろいろあるでしょう
一つの現象についたっていうのは
そこで知恵ある人は別になんのことなく
そういうことかと見ているだけ
だから それは仏教でいう至福感
幸福感なんですね この安定した心の波
で まあ例えば美しい公園に行ったり
どこかへ行っても 美しい自然の山を見たり
何とか見たり 夜景を見たりして
ああすごいすごいと感動する人は
他の何とか見たらものすごく気持ち悪くなるんですよ
他の何か見たら そうでないと
あれを見てああ素晴らしいと感動できないんです
同じ働きだから ですから
そういうどっちもないと
何か酷いことを見ても
一般の人はひどい ああ
これは恐ろしいなと思う
見たって まあそういうことかと見ているだけで
みんなもう涙出るほど感動するようなものを見たって
そういうことかと見ているだけで
それは智慧の世界 それはまあかるにでも味わうことはできるし
ですから この日常生活の中で
ほんの僅かな時間でも決めて
でも智慧で 智慧っていうのはちょっと強引に使わないと出てこないもんなんですね
智慧で生きてみようとする
無常の角度で物事を見ている
無我の角度で物事を見ていると
その状態は智慧というんです
で 一応ヘイトはそこら辺で終了します
次にあるのは まあ心をまあ区別してくれるんですね
18種類の心があって
アヘーとかというんです
それはこちらで書いてあると思いますよ
五門陰転心 それから五識が 2つのセットがあります
領受心 2つありますし
水道心というものは 3つあります
確定心 1つと で 正気心ですね
そこは 18ですね そういうのは心の基本的な働きなんですね
結局は 五門陰転心というのは前説明しましたから
これパンチャドゥーラワッジのチップというんですけど
あの眼耳鼻舌身にあるこの敏感感覚
感受性なんですね 眼耳鼻舌身に何か情報が触れたら
すぐ受けるように状態ができているんですね
目に何か形が入ったら
すぐそれを受けられるように
この状態があるんですね
それが五門陰転という心で
で それ心だから やっぱり私にはわからないかもしれませんだけど
この 例えば音が物質であるし
耳に音が触れちゃうと
すぐ我々の意識が耳に行っちゃうんですね
行ってから音を受け取るんですね
音を受け取るんじゃなくて
音に触れて その感覚 感情ですか
受を受け取っちゃうんですね
音は聞こえませんだけど
受を解釈して 頭の中で
胃の中で受を解釈して
音だ なんとか音だと解釈するんですけど
音は聞こえませんですけど
そこで目に何かが映っちゃうと
心がそこに行って あ 何か見えてるんだって
じゃあ受け取らなくちゃと
というふうな働きがあるんです
それはまあほんの落ち着いている自分の心を見ると
まあわかるんですよ 瞑想する時でも
いくらか まあこれは瞑想の結果で書いているもので
心理学だからね 例えば瞑想してふくらみ自己を見ているんだ
そこで耳に何か音が入った瞬間に
耳 音が触れると すぐ心がそこに行って音として受け取っちゃうんですね
もし心がそこに行かなかったならば
世の中で音があっても聞こえないんです
だから我々は落ち着いてないんですね
心が耳に行ったり 鼻に行ったり
口に行ったり 体に行ったり
目に行ったり もう走りっぱなしなんですね
ずっとものすごい速いスピードで走ってるんですね
だから すぐどこに音が入って
音が入る瞬時にそれを受け取られるし
目に何か入る瞬時にも受け取られる
それぐらい強烈な速さで
この五門陰転っていうのはもう回ってるんですね
回っていて 例えば大胆な何か目に入ったと
あまり大胆なこと見えちゃったんだから
五蘊陰天がそこに止まって
それでもう活動始まるんですね
見たものはどういうものかだとか
その時は人を喋ってもわからないんですよ
誰が体触ってもわからない
その瞬間で 五蘊陰天はそこに行ってないんです
そうするとかなり大きい声で喋らなくちゃいけないんです
あるいは何回も肩を叩かないと
何回も肩を叩くと それぐらい物質的な働きあるでしょうに
そこでそこで物質的な変化が起こるでしょうし
それぞれの物質的な変化が起こると
また五蘊陰天がそこに行ったら
あ 何ですか？と それからそこに行っちゃいますけど
で 五蘊陰天 こういう風に落ち着かなくて
あっちこっち心が走り回らなかったならば
一つにきちんと据えて見たり感じたりすることができる
そうすると他のものは全く聞こえないし
わからないし で とにかくこの心の基本的な働きで
どこが情報ないか情報ないかと必死になって五蘊陰天が動いていて
情報が触れたらすぐそれを受け取ります
ですから そちらには別に貪瞋痴やら不貪不瞋痴とは関係なく
それは心の働きなんですね
ですから これには無陰という無陰身と言ったんだから
原因ない心という意味ではなくて
貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋痴がない心という意味なんですね
で 次に出てくるのはこのパンチャ・ドゥーラワジヤナ
ディパンチャ・ドゥーラワジヤナという
ディパンチャ・ヴィンヤーナ
パンチャ・ヴィンヤーナというのは五識ですね
五識というのは眼耳鼻舌身の識なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身に識が生まれる
それはチャクラ・ヴィンヤーナ
ソト・ヴィンヤーナ ガーナ・ヴィンヤーナ
ジウハー・ヴィンヤーナ
カーヤ・ヴィンヤーナというんですね
で 目に何か入ったら見える
耳に音が入ったら聞こえる
それだけの五識 その五識を二つのセット
一つは悪いものを感じる場合といいものを感じる場合に分けているんですね
まあその分け方もどうか分かりませんだけど
どちらの立場で分けた方がいいか分かりませんだけど
やっぱりもしかすると一般的な分け方でいえば
やっぱり人間は音は聞くんだ
聞くんだけど 人間の耳にはいい音もあったりして
悪い音もあったりする
人間の主観的なことには関係なく
例えば味にしたっても
我々の主観的な好みと関係なく
体に合う味と合わない味があるんでしょうね
そういう意味かもしれません
観測にしたっても どんな観測も人間の体に合うというわけでもないし
合う観測と合わない観測がありますね
体の場合 ですから そういう二つの分け方でしょう
と思いますけど で 体に合わない色声香味触
触れたりするとやっぱり苦しいですね
それはカルマの結果 悪いカルマの結果だという
体に合う色声香味触 そこに触れる場合はいいカルマの結果だと呼ぶんですね
ということは 人間 普通なら人間は見たいものは見られて
聞きたいものは聞かれて
味わいたいものを味わえて
体でも触れたいものに触れて生活できるということは
普通に言えば 贅沢で言えば幸福でしょうし
自分 自分の希望通りなお家があったりとかね
希望通りの食べ物を食べたりとかね
という それは普通に我々いうのはお金がいっぱいあったり
ちゃんと収入が入ったり
まあ気にちゃんと気が合う相手が見つかったりして
また子供も自分にとって随分随分気が合ってるんだとか
そういう状態で喜びを感じるでしょうね
それ人間が幸福だ幸福だ
過去世大変徳を積んでいる人だとか言ったりはしますよ
でも アビダンマからの立場から
科学的な立場から言うとその人の目には見たいものは見られるし
聞きたい音は聞かれるし
味わいたいものは味わえるし
それだけ 例えば子供がとんでもないことをやっていると
自分としては見たくないことを目に見える
そうすると 自分の心の中で苦しみが生まれる
それは人間が子供が不良に走ってるんだから苦しんでるんだよというだけのことで
その人間の世界ではそういうふうにしか説明できない
本当のこと 仏教から見れば
見たくないものは見える
で 子供は喋るでしょうに
それで聞きたくない音を聞こえる
で 子供は学校に行かないで寝ているんだと
そこに何が起きたかというと
ただ単に自分の目に何か入ってるだけなんですよ
この目に入ってることは
本当は見たくないことなんですね
朝になっても子供はベッドの中にもう学校に行きたくないと
なんとか言いながら寝ていると
それは見たくないもので
それで随分苦しみを感じる
ああ 登校拒否しているんだ
これどういうことか どうすればいいんだ
あだこだとか そこに並ならぬ苦しみが生まれてくる
ですから アビダンマではそういうふうに
人間の世界とは関係なく
物質も科学的に分析しちゃいますからね
そこで人間がいるんだとか
私がいるんだという立場ではないんだからね
見たくないものを見られる
聞きたくないものは聞かれると
で 子供は暴力を振るうならば
もう触れたくないものに触れると
その三つは固まるだけ
それで不幸だ 不幸だ あだこだと言ったりする
ですからこの 同じくアビダンマでは
やっぱりそういうふうに眼耳鼻舌身に色声香味触というものは触れる
その場合はいいと悪い二つに分けられると
ですから五識はセット二つあるんですね
アクサライバーカとクサラバーカと
そちらの場合も私たちの貪瞋痴には関係ない
貪瞋痴に関係なく 聞きたい音と聞きたくない音っていうのはもう決まってるんだから
例えば金属の音っていうのはいろいろありまして
でもある音は我々は音楽と言うんですね
ある金属の音にはものすごくもう気持ち悪くなるんだと
体ももう全部神経まで痺れてしまうんだととも言うし
例えばあるでしょうね
もう金属でも何かこの儀式も何かでもやっちゃうと聞いていられない
ものすごく体がもう反応を起こす音もあるし
でもピアノにしてもバイオリンにしても全部金属の音でしょうに
シンバルにしても あれ急にいきなりでっかい声で大きなシンバルっていうんですか？なんかあの板２つ
あれ ああいうものはドーンと
驚くでしょうに それでも耳は驚くんだけど
あまり音の凄さに 別に聞きたくないという感じは生まれてこないでしょ
ただちょっと驚いちゃいますけど
その代わりにもう何か金属をまたノコギリみたいな
ありますね そういうものもギーギーと音を出しながらやったりすると
もう耳がものすごい痛くなっちゃうんですね
ですから それは私たちにとってはどうすることもできない
我々の聴覚はそういうふうにできているんですね
ある音は受け取る ある音は受け取ると嫌な反応を起こしちゃう
ですから この五識の 五識のセット二つがあります
それも無因身だというんです
貪瞋痴とは関係ない 次に出てくるのは水道身という心
三つありますし この水道身三つっていうのは
この入った情報も基本的な処理しなくちゃいけない
[背景音楽]